did you guys notice
adam was down a little bit yesterday
afternoon i don't know if you guys
caught that or not it was a little bit
down a little bit yesterday afternoon
when the news came out about
you know uh kanye west and kim
kardashian i saw him
i saw him a little bit uh broke my heart
but you seemed opportunistic do you seem
like uh you know there was uh
you know in a prior podcast you have
given kim some love
yeah so what do you think about kim and
connie getting divorced
or is that official well i mean that's
public enforcement looks like it's
happening do you know how many kids they
have together by the way
four four kids together four kids
together
wow yeah you know what i found
interesting yesterday
i saw adam's changing the way he spells
his name it's k
a d a m soft k
getting ready keeping that k crew
together
shout out to the chorus koi boy mafia
yeah no but honestly what do you think
about it you you
i told you the conversation i had the
last conversation i know but how you
feel
were you surprised when you got the ward
or did you have some
kai told me he broke the news to me he
said guess who's getting a divorce
he goes i'll give you three guesses i
was like he's like big news
i go melanie and trump number one uh
and who else did i guess guys i guess
someone else i don't know who it was but
um
and he goes i'll give you one more guess
and this is like this hit it's close to
home to you i said oh damn kim and kanye
but i told you this what the last
conversa we all know that one of my best
friends chris humphries married you were
with us
this week yeah i was with chris last
week with his new girlfriend we were in
miami
i was in the wedding the whole thing and
the last conversation i had with kim she
says
i envisioned myself as an elizabeth
taylor elizabeth taylor was married how
many times eight or nine times
so basically i was like oh this is the
last conversation i had with her however
long ago
and she said like i'll be married a
bunch of times so this is now number
three
and she'll be going on number four the
question is
who's next yeah right yeah she's like
she seems like the type of person that
likes to be married you wouldn't think
you'd get into a relationship have four
kids and not think it would last for a
while
so but you know he's kind of gone off i
mean she's been with him for yeah
almost nine years yeah for sure that's
that's yeah that's long for her
by the way you know elizabeth taylor
married richard burton twice
yeah exactly married divorced married
remix yeah so you're saying there's hope
for my buddy chris
well no whatever what i'm at 50 days
here's
here's a question here's a seven two
crazy
crazy crazy question yeah and see what
you say to this
who do you think she will get remarried
who do you think she'll get married
i know who it won't be who a white guy
okay
so who do you think she'll give me yeah
i went there who do you think she'll get
married
um okay so a
question to the audience out there would
you
be interested in marrying kim here's the
catch
you got to pay for her kids you got to
raise your kids you got to deal with
kanye's the stepdad why do you have to
pay for him she's getting
i'm just saying that's the catch because
who's going to be like i'll take down
kim
i don't think she needs your money
though i don't think she i don't think
kim is
marrying too because she needs your
money the kind of girl that
it doesn't want a man who's like high
profile
yeah bring it bring in the heat she's
gonna want somebody that's got
strong personality okay so it'll be an
athlete or performer
maybe someone that's definitely in the
public eye in a big way
um ronnie james 10 years i'm not sure
maybe
i think she's gone past the athlete like
she did the athlete thing the reggie
bush
chris she's gone to the rapper thing i
think she's gonna go
more the political i think you're right
prestigious she wants to be a lawyer
she's like a little bit more clout
you know like not the rapper kind of
clout the politician
the investor the billionaire kind of
clout i think she's thinking
next level just don't think elon musk
happened and elon musk typed
i've got one there you go obama divorces
michelle he marries
they just think that um that's the route
that she would go
uh a black high up politician who
like a michael steele who's the former
rnc
chair uh van jones
who else we got yeah this [ __ ] people
are saying that on social media they're
throwing her with van jones
really yeah they're like hoping it
happens that'd be a good reality she's
going to capitalize on it somehow she's
so smart
but i think she has made a little
transition where she really does want to
make a difference in the world
she sprung a few people are you a fan i
am a fan of
anybody that can i i'm i'm not like
there's a difference
i'm like i'm like i like him i've hung
out i know certain hours not to call you
because you're watching keeping up with
kardashians
that's that's what i was basically i
don't watch that stuff
i don't like i never i i mean if i'm
with a girl and they're watching it yeah
they'll like i'll watch it
but i don't want i'm not a fan like that
but i i actually am a fan
i got like she was a friend at one point
so like i like her
you are you rooting for her yeah are you
rooting
she's not ruining again the whole family
i'm rooting for him i mean if you don't
like him don't watch him
i love him i've never watched keeping up
with kardashians once i don't even know
what the show's like dude you're
armenian what are you doing have you
gotta remember
i know a restaurant called kate
mantellini in woodland hills and i'm
sitting there and it was uh chloe
and lamar they said what are these guys
doing we're shooting keeping up a car
down oh that's cool i used to eat there
like five times a week because it's
right next to the office i had
but i am a very big fan
of seeing her kick some major ass
i just i just i'm a fan i'd love to see
kim
make a major come up constantly there's
something very um
uh uh uh attractive not even not even
looks white there's something very
attractive about her personality
very the way she carries her herself the
way she does the the interviews the way
she conducts herself
uh i don't think that family is going
away and i'd be so
curious you know what their next move is
did you uh this is actually a perfect
culmination of
politics pop culture rap
business did you hear what um kanye
called
chris jenner yeah i did chris john un
chris jong-un yeah she's the run's a
tight ship yeah yeah
that's pretty clever chris jong-un
he said that on twitter or he said that
publicly or what was that exactly
publicly i think it was on twitter yeah
yeah pretty uh pretty ballsy so what
happens to con
you're saying his days are numbered so i
mean he called out his mother-in-law it
was the el jefe
all right so we talked about kim what
happens with kanye now because i i don't
know if you know this
he didn't win the president sorry you
know
heartbroken yeah he's a genius creator i
think he gets you know he's got that
place in montana just creating songs
albums go back to that
i mean he's not probably looking for a
big high-profile relationship and i
would doubt that he has
any struggles in flying women when
needed so but he did say
one good girl is worth a thousand
[ __ ] so
i think a guy did say that i think a guy
like kanye
maybe feels like he got overshadowed and
he's going to man i've done some things
in my life and it's
all forgotten because i'm with this
crazy family i got a prediction i just
thought of it
i think this trump kanye 2024 thing is
happening
it's happening they're both they're both
going to be single
they're both going to be divorced and
they're going to end up together
maybe that last part was a little
farfetched however uh the other part i
think is good i think they're going to
be uh
trump and kanye got a nice little bright
future for you it's kind of like the
ebony and ivory version of frank sinatra
got a bigger website who's got a bigger
upset kim or
kanye kim not even close not even close
i haven't closed
really yeah really do you agree
do you guys agree or not i think she's
got more mass appeal than kanye i don't
got some more ass appeal that
you know i don't believe you've never
watched one episode of keep in mind
never once
that means you can jen never puts it on
the tv i've never never
[ __ ] watches it
i couldn't tell you but i know morale is
always talking about you know she she
she's armenian she's army now she's a
fan of that sure yeah you know
she can use as her model uh j-lo and
a-rod who would have ever thought they
would be together and that seems to kind
of work
you mesh these two superstar brands and
by the way who do you but somebody said
some who do you think she'll be with
somebody commented the rock
another person said mike tyson somebody
said lynn wood
who he wouldn't she would end up with
meek mill interesting
she someone said she was spotted doing
something meek mill someone said jack
mom
jeff bezos p diddy uh jeff bezos
uh uh uh who else we got here hillary
von miller
von miller's available yeah von miller
yeah he just had a bad breakup i think
she's done the athlete thing she's get
it these guys times have numbered i
think
at this point in her life by the way she
just turned 40
uh if the rock hadn't just got married i
could actually see that
combining those two brands changing the
world yeah i think that's the level that
she
would be that's the level she's on if if
her and rock were together you know the
rock married an armenian
he's got an armenian wife now really
yeah so
he likes our team getting ready for kim
yeah i think i i don't i mean look
kanye's upside what's his upside another
album
right like ain't nobody he has no
like nobody's voting for that guy i
think kim can attach herself to a
high-profile person whether it's a
a must type a rock type and i would not
be part of that
you send her a text her number you know
you should tender sorry about me again
it's been like a decade sorry about that
about the news
you know you need anything
have you thought about bitcoin
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye